ils campent depuis deux mois devant un
groupe scolaire d'aubervilliers une
centaine de squatters ont été délogés ce
matin et sont revenus immédiatement
après le départ de la police
une affaire qui a provoqué des remous au
sein du gouvernement après la visite
improvisée sur place de la secrétaire
d'état aux droits de l'homme rama yade
guillaume bart et 7h30 ce matin les
forces de l'ordre interviennent pour
déloger les familles 112 personnes et la
plupart en situation régulière qui
campent depuis deux mois devant un
groupe scolaire
le climat est tendu les squatteurs
résiste pendant plus d'une heure il ya
des femmes ici il ya des enfants ici il
ya des nouveaux nés par missiles à des
femmes en fait ici oui il ya des
français parmi nous ici il ya des
réfugiés politiques ici elles ou dans un
pays des droits donc et donnez nous des
endroits où nous on paie a laissé sa les
animés vous n'avez rien à nous proposer
donc vous allez me gt en quoi dollars
alors qu'on est déjà dans la rue nous on
dit rien du tout cinq personnes
interpellées des temps de démonter mais
une situation qui n'a pas évolué
quelques minutes plus tard les familles
quand toujours à même le sol et 11h
surprise rama yade la secrétaire d'état
aux droits de l'homme arrive sur les
lieux
j'apprends à la radio que à oberwil
poussé des gens
donc j'ai improvisé cette visite à
aubervilliers quelqu'un communiste
lorsque je dis moi c'est que ce domaine
là il vaut mieux ne pas donner de leçons
et qu'on veut mettre tous ensemble pour
travailler une solution donc c'est ce
que je suis venu sur ce déplacement est
profond controversé et peut-être premier
faux pas pour rama yade
le premier ministre françois fillon l'a
convoqué pour s'expliquer et lui
demander à l'avenir plus de concertation
avec ses collègues du gouvernement quant
à la municipalité communiste
d'aubervilliers elle juge que rama yade
conteste une décision de justice puisque
c'est le tribunal de bobigny qui a
ordonné cette expulsion pour troubles à
l'ordre public
est une démarche inutile
c'est une démarche provocatrice alors
qu'elle avait l'occasion de dire au
préfet écoutez fait une table ronde pour
qu examiner la situation les dossiers de
ces personnes du point de vue de leur
logement
ce soir une cinquantaine de squatters
sont toujours sur les lieux déterminés à
y passer la nuit